karen b chez whole of pop professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou
bonjour qu'un de bêcher golovkov merci
de répondre à nos questions sur rt
france est ce que c'est une
normalisation des relations entre la
russie et les etats-unis que cette
annonce de donald trump en souvent que
la russie a été expulsé un de ce g8 et
en 2014
je ne sais pas s'il s'agit d'une
normalisation des relations entre la
russie et les etats unis en revanche
crap pour sa part lui continué sur sa
logique de volonté de lutte contre de
mécanismes à ces primaires de la
globalisation ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'ils le remettent en cause la
supériorité des états unis dire le
contraire mais en revanche il veut
casser en quelque sorte ce mécanisme qui
sont plus dans la logique des démocrates
est là en fait que l'on voit que tout le
reflet d'un combat intérieur de la
politique américaine
ce qui conduit donc de manière assez
logique à ce qui se retournera vers la
russie qui a quand même un pib qui
correspond à 3 % du pib mondial à l'inde
qui a 8 % du pib mondial c'est à dire
des chiffres qui sont même au dessus
d'un certain nombre de pays du g7 comme
la france ou la grande-bretagne qui sont
un peu plus de 2%
l'italie ou le canada un peu plus d'un
pour cent donc en fait il remet un petit
peu les choses en place effectivement si
le g7 doit être représentatif des
puissances actuelles
dans ce cas là
il ne peut plus être à 7 il faut changer
le format effectivement et comment cette
annonce a été accueillie du côté moscou
pour l'instant vous savez il ya beaucoup
de d'annonce qui sont faites il faudra
voir dans quelle mesure à seront
réalisés comment elles seront réalisées
et six trains pour a les moyens de
réaliser ce qu'il annonce
la russie est toujours après a participé
aux négociations internationales
d'autant plus qu'elle est une puissance
internationale qu'elle compte sur la
scène internationale comme on l'a vu
depuis 2015 lorsqu'elle est revenue avec
la possibilité de faire revenir la
crimée lors de la crise provoquée en
ukraine avec la russie avec la syrie
pardon ou la russie a permis de mettre
en danger la domination de l'état
islamique dans la région et ainsi de
contrer le jeu des groupes atlantiste
donc la russie est une puissance
internationale
a priori elle est toujours ouverte au
dialogue les problèmes de il n'y a pas
d'accord tu es en déclarant ce qu'est ce
qu'il faut attendre c'est prochaine
heures ces prochains jours ces
prochaines semaines on l'a dit cette
réunion devait avoir lieu prochainement
connais pas encore la date
est-ce que dès la prochaine réunion on
pourrait voir par exemple la russie et
l'inde de l'australie la corée du sud
convié un g7 plus + 4 par exemple s'il
ya plus de chances qu'il y ait un g7 +4
que de voir leur tour un g8
parce que dans ce cas là ce serait une
reconnaissance directe d'un retour à la
normale dans les relations avec la
russie
et je ne pense pas que actuellement
l'ambiance encore assez russophone
malheureusement en occident que ce soit
dans le cas de l'union européenne ou
avec les démocrates aux états unis
permettent réellement de normaliser la
situation
par ailleurs c'est peut être également
dans l'intérêt de train peint puisque ça
permet de donner de l'importance à des
pays qui ont un certain poids sans
forcément toujours avoir un poids
politique par exemple l'inde ou la corée
du sud qui est quand même plutôt un
élément on dire stratégiques de la
politique américaine en asie
donc ça permettra de se permettre
effectivement de renforcer la position
américaine dans ce côté là ça peut
trouver effectivement un soutien dans le
plan atlantiste pour trucks a présenté
également l'intérêt de contourner la
chine est en revanche elle donnait pas
l'intégrer dans ses processus
merci cachet goal of quoi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou